ciao ragazzi di bettati video sul mio
canale oggi se accompagnate il mio
congiunto enrico mio fratello e si
staccano vi ho chiesto di farmi sapere
quali sono delle curiosità delle domande
che volevate farci non pensavo che
sarebbero arrivate così tante da piccoli
terminate tutti e quattro nella stessa
stanza
no no a piccoli con lo stato dei nonni
tutto grillo io capivo che i nonni
però ti sentivi l'escluso io non volevo
perché corsi 80 puro che cardine stand
by il cane chiosa vecchio il ribalta
l'inter vivo ricordo accanto quando
siamo invece dietro ai più grandi
dormivamo così io dal mio con gabriele
ritorniamo già nel gp nella norma
tornito con enrico naturalmente io avrei
capito da chi devi ma la risata di
enrico amico quando era piccola ha perso
e fa ha ingoiato alle delle 7 per lui
schifano bello provano viti store il
pinguino di ristoro esatto
ti sembra aver iniziato perché tre
secoli ad enrico stai così tu sei questo
livello non è ubriaco ve lo giuro
non possiamo uscire casarano medico di
una persona che portò stile perché
tossisce da sempre coming out le fatto
prima con i tuoi fratelli
no l'ho fatto prima con dei miei amici e
per fattore che fratelli però prima le
cugine con le mie cugine poi è il cane e
poi gli ultimi fratelli meta che ricordo
che lo dissi a gabriele avevo il terrore
ma non è stato super fallo l'odissea
gianluigi è stato persona perché hanno
capito e enrico noi avevamo fatto tutto
ad una scommessa essere medico l'ha
capito e reggono c'è una massa devo
dirti che mi ricordo che allora stavo un
ragazzo gli dissi io questo ragazzo non
sono amici ma stare insieme che cosa
rarissima come non hai capito come fatto
nelle marche video limite della risposta
per fiere tutti perché ma io mica mi
chiedo se magari quando conosco come ha
fatto vostra madre a non impazzire con
quattro maschi arrivati nel giorno
entrati in casa avevamo cosparso tutto
quanto il salone di borotalco three
gardeccia ci lanciamo da un lato
all'altro in mutande la più grande
litigata che avete fatto mai fatta mai
fatta noi non abbiamo mai litigato
no noi abbiamo litigato ragazze no io ho
litigato con gabriel e io ho dedicato
credo anche un widget tu eri cioè tutti
hanno dedicato che aprirà le magliette
mai mai mai
provvederemo un difetto che ti dà molto
fastidio dell'altro c'è ma non tuo mio
certo impossibile velocemente
praticamente perché se non tanto io
espongo il mio e poi ecco critichiamo
quando parla di con guglielmo lui non ci
ascolta qualsiasi cosa tu possa fare lui
se si è prefissato un qualcosa non ti
ascolterà mai parla non mi dà più
fastidio perché ormai ci ho fatto
l'abitudine quindi o ti parlo più andare
veloci mario più buio una soglia
dell'attenzione molto molto molto molto
come se avessi la testa per le derbi qua
per metà da un'altra parte e quando vado
nell'altra parte mi stacco e poi il
ritorno alla realtà
che cosa è successo di fatto bene a
castello di enrico che chi però è lento
stai lì capito a cercare di marghera
saggio cardiaco per lui stop mi sono
arrivati a livelli che tipo stavo
morendo di sé dal letto bocca secca non
mi sono persa col vizio peggiore
dell'altro me ne sto cercando 13 tanti
che poche cose a un genio posso dirlo
allegati quale tra quelli che si possono
dire non ce ne sono tra quelli che si
possono dire non ne trovo nessuno è
ancora chi ce l'ha più lungo di cui 2 ma
che intendono invaso il pollice
non ho mai visto enrico ma ho visto
certi quali sono i vostri segni
zodiacali di cimeli vedete bene che deve
vedere quell'aspetto sei tu che io sono
sagittario mio toro il milione del
sagittario perché sono un simpatico e un
amabile e amichevole superficiale con
problemi attenzione e difficoltà nel
mantenere i rapporti
enrico è un pesa culo c però non è che
devi fare l'elenco delle cose negative
del toro di le cose [ __ ] nel tono
perché si sa che il segno migliore
è un pesa culo che quando qualcosa
cambia e si modifica vorrebbe morire è
piuttosto che allora io mi sento
benissimo
sì all amico e anche super divertente
uno che sta bene tutte le situazioni
dai non scherzare lui e leale molto
attento alle cose concrete
chi è più basso tra i due guerrieri no
la faccio se tu mi dici motivo di pazzia
io ti risponde con fiori pazzia e quando
uno non c'è più le cose da sparare vuol
dire che ha perso e continuo no perché
non è detto che a ping pong e perde più
bravo ma dimmi un motivo per questo
pazzo per grande tutti in famiglia
abbiamo fatto un gioco sia la classifica
del livello di follia tra noi cucini al
primo posto c'era aprire aprile al
secondo posto pieno merito
guglielmo io ero tipo al quinto posto ma
se ne vanno riviste passo di
pierfrancesco ma vabbè per francesco
potrebbe essere benissimo un assassino
nessuno lo sapeva quello che faccio sco
potrebbe benissimo avere una cultura di
latte in casa che si diverte a far
combattere la notte berlino combattere
formica e dei ricordi come a lavorare in
famiglia pessimo borri in realtà siamo
molto fortunati e ma molte famiglie che
lavorano insieme stanno sempre a
litigare proprio perché tra familiari
c'è meno attenzione al rapporto
lavorativo non merita al contrario nel
lavoro stiamo superattenti che fa
impazzire per aspetta colorino una cosa
riguardo che mi è sfuggita a taglio chi
canta meglio io no dai fammi un pezzo
[Musica]
no no no no no no no vuol dire fai
chiara e più secchione a scuola nessuno
dei due alfa ceca care alle elementari
era un mostro un treno prima cosa è
successo che non ho chiamato libro dalle
mediche e io vi giuro non ho aperto un
libro ma perché se perché non mi andava
io ero attentissimo alle elezioni che
devo domandavo facevo curiosissimo a
casa non facevo niente io ero this
attentissimo alle elezioni stanno sempre
a disegnare uno aspetta anche io che lo
descriviamo e poi ero molto bravo in
alcune materie che mi piacevano in altre
bravissimo a copiare ma non è un
insegnamento ragazzi se potesse non
andiamo nello studiare molto di più ero
bravissimo nelle materne indirizzo da
dire questo non e studiavo però ero
bravissimo e sono riuscito in un'ora di
compito in classe a fare i due compiti
differenti 18 e mezzo nell'altro 8
aumento sei sempre stato un genietto
certo per tutta contenerla sempre io il
mio vicino di banco che fra l'altro
lettori per compito era bocciato e lei
sant'atto san paolo tra vedi bocciato
per cento tre cose che ti piacciono il
carattere di tuo fratello
stimo molto l'intelligenza di vivo il
suo parere i dem e molto anche
talentuoso cioè checa pure io sì bravo a
famose disegnare trovare delle soluzioni
anche creative ed è molto è un po
all'apparenza che lo sai cosa sereno un
geniale gioviale ed è molto un giocatore
non siete niente geniali 23 trovare un
terzo to intelligente sicuro talentuoso
sicuro cioè chiaramente inferiore a me
però è come terzo direi gay
ecco hai una qualità molto rara che è
quella dell'incriminazione cioè se tu
sei zero risulti che 6 10 cielo
imbastisca però non mi voglio riesci a
dimostrare più di quello che si è quindi
molto carismatico a non certo meno
ipocrita fratello preferito non esiste
un fratello preferito tutti alla pari
per motivi diversi di questo la vita ha
detto da sera l'ho già detto è passato
per me dico il mio fratello preferito
quando si tratta tipo di ideare cose
pensare cose fare chiacchiere più
possiamo dire che siamo noi due tanto
gli altri denuncia riguarda non riguarda
di rimanere di media perché vi
somigliate a coppie non lo riesco a
capire è vero perché io dico ci
assomigliamo secondo le persone di capi
religiosi che si assomigliano perché
mamma avuto medico gabriele miei
compagni escono però pende da tetti di
sadismo mamma è che ben ciato io lo pago
di scuola che quando ho fatto il liceo
eravamo al supermercato sta vagliando
mamma c'è la questo ragazzo che mi ha
affermato che mi disse ma se guglielmo
mi sono girato ho guardato ma non ci ha
pensato ero preso dal panico e proprio
adesso più distratta ecco la distrazione
di enrico guarda 22 se guglielmo gian
luigi gabriele e enrico perché enrico
con la re perché perché anche perché il
nostro papa si chiama giuseppe il nonno
gino e ho sempre
se dovessi chiamare giacomo un così bel
nome giacomo gus e protettivo nei
confronti di enrico sì ma non lo dico
perché guardando un paiolo quindi non
posso rispondere
cosa deve dire che io sono più
protettivo nei confronti di guglielmo ci
proteggiamo ricordo più bello che avete
insieme piace lo avevo quattro anni
arrivo non era ancora materana la
partita è sì qual è ha io e un altro mio
cugino quando errico era piccolissimo
bravo paolo facevamo da ragazzini le
missioni in questo video salendo sulle
cabine infilandoci di per tutti sotto
questa sorta di costruzione quindi in
mezzo a stip ania ruggini ti fa andare a
morire come topi e ci guardavamo enrico
con noi ma non ci divertivamo tipo a
lanciar cielo da una cabina all'altra
pieno dare un arco mai caduto ma perché
e cosa che ha mai il tableau shore dante
anche un altro bel ricordo che ho con te
che cosa cercate nel vostro partner
il cervello si si si ebbene sì il
cervello però in realtà quello che cerco
è che ti dia l'idea che se una cosa
giusta
dopo mi dice oppure se mi prendono al
curling sue dalla vita in giù anche il
cuore seguirà ma non è vero manco quello
quindi in realtà la chiave è non cercare
niente perché quando non trovi aggiunto
io per esempio non sono mai stato
fidanzato fino a qualche mese fa e la
sera prima ricordo io dissi a un mio
amico
basta più mi sono stufato di cercare una
relazione campano lo pensa video però
certo chi rimorchi di più io niente
[Risate]
perché non vogliamo vederlo siamo
riavere a fini questo video dalle 5
ringrazio enrico per preso parte questo
video ringrazio guglielmo mirra limitato
ma ringraziamo soprattutto voi per
averci seguito
mamma mia e ricordate l'amica biscotti
che muoversi come sempre vi invitiamo a
iscrivervi a questo canale lasciateci un
bel 2 pollici 50 e soprattutto lasciate
sul commento qua sotto nel quale ci fate
sapere e votate chi dei due ha vinto il
confronto
la storia si infittisce to be continued